nous avons acquis l'expérience depuis
maintenant malheureusement depuis le
mois de mai au mois de mars nous avons
acquis une certaine expérience
d'organisation nous avons acquis un
certain pragmatisme que nous avons
travaillé avec notamment les
professionnels de santé
nous avons appris à travailler
différemment et aujourd'hui si on devait
aider à mettre en place la campagne de
vaccination nous saurions le faire en
lien avec les professionnels de santé en
lien avec la préfecture en lien avec
avec nos partenaires nous saurons le
faire
le département de l'essonne c'est un
vaste département des très grandes
communes comme every vous avez des et
toutes petites communes dans le sud de
l'essonne mais chacun a sa part pour ah
oui en tout cas a fait ses preuves en
tout cas de volontarisme dans les
différents messages qu'on pût être
échangé les uns avec les autres si on
vous avait appelé il ya trois ou quatre
semaines pour nous dire voilà on met en
place une stratégie de vaccination où il
a six semaines qu'elle roule pourriez
vous jouez à quel moment vous pourriez
la jouer à ce qu'on voit là où on aurait
pu accompagner la stratégie de
vaccination il dire voilà ce qui se
passe quand les chiffres tombent du
nombre de maxine et en allemagne hors
d'israël dans d'autres endroits du globe
et quand on regarde les chiffres lundi
matin où d'immenses du nombre de
vaccinés en france
évidemment ça questionne plus que de
même plus que ça questionne ça interroge
voir ça a mis certains élus extrêmement
en colère
moi je me prémunir cette colère je reste
concentré sur ce que j'ai à faire je
reste pragmatique
depuis le début de la crise vous avez
inventé moi je fais pas partie du même
parti politique qu elle présente la
république considère que pendant cette
crise qui est particulièrement anxiogène
la multiplication des attaques accentue
cette ce volet roach et gêne certains le
font très bien et sait très bien qu'ils
le fassent et l'aspect démocratique
mais jusqu'à maintenant dans mes réseaux
autour de moi j'ai toujours fait très
attention à ne pas être dans cette danse
est cette réflexion-là et danseuses vert
voilà depuis dimanche
je ne pouvais plus me taire et il
fallait dire à ce moment là que nous
sommes là et qu'il faut que que sur
cette stratégie conçois qu'on vienne
nous voir comme nous posez des questions
pour savoir qu'elle est de notre point
de vue j'ai pas qu'on a raison flicaille
de notre point de vue qu'elle serait là
vers des stratégies à adopter pour
rendre la stratégie de vaccination la
plus efficace